attention attention attention un petit
problème technique
on va interrompre voilà c'est bon c'est
bon ils peuvent partir que se passe-t-il
oui les joueurs qui ont commencé un
petit peu trop vite avant que c'est un
signe un petit peu donc de de stress
chez la part d'arnaud et de boris donc
boris donc ce vieux monsieur ce grand
monsieur des échecs et donc des joueurs
donc en pleine concentration
oui c'était un exercice bien entendu
très difficile de commenter des blitz
nous allons essayer dans ce troisième
but de départage jean-luc de faire le
maximum pour donner le plus
d'indications possible aux spectateurs
mais ce qu'on peut quand même retenir de
ces deux 2 2 premier de ses deux
premières parties
c'est le temps qui a joué quand même un
rôle très très important et ce n'est pas
du tout étonnant alors on a du mal un
petit peu à suivre ce qui se passe
donc apparemment les deux joueurs ont
on changeait donc arnaud hauchard prend
les prends les blancs dans la dans la
partie décisive puisque maintenant c'est
la dernière partie de ce match et arnaud
hauchard devra l'emporter s'il veut donc
le se qualifier et donc une tâche
extrêmement difficile mais tout à fait
envisageable vu carnot a obtenu quand
même deux bonnes parties avec les blancs
donc la partie a commencé donc c'est une
anglaise cette fois donc c'est une
anglaise classique donc
arnaud qui jouent eux trois un système
rampant où il va éventuellement essayer
de contrôler à il s'installe au centre
directement et boris aussi donc boris
qui avait joué ce type de position il ya
très très longtemps contre les meilleurs
joueurs de la planète dont petrosyan je
crois voilà un sacrifice de pions de la
part d'arnaud char qui a joué au b2b
cats le pion été en prise par le
cavalier ans et 6 donc jean luc hees qui
lie à une justification tout à fait oui
après cavaliers prend bekkat damas
catéchèse suivi de dessins qui gagnerait
lecavalier
oui toujours à cause d'un clouage ce
cavalier ne pouvant pas bougé le roi
étant en 8
donc là dans cette position on peut on
peut dire que les blancs réussi à
installer à forcer le cavalier c6 avenir
en a cinq
ce qui n'est pas une très bonne case
puisqu'il est excentré et qu'il aura
beaucoup de mal à revenir en jeu et il
installe un cavalier en d5 ce qui est
une bonne chose car en cas des changes
bien sûr on reprend dupont c'est et les
blancs vont pouvoir avoir du contre jeu
sur la colonne c est attaqué le pion en
c7 qui pourra être défendu quand même
relativement facilement par la touriste
est notamment jean-luc oui tout à fait
donc le pion c7 qui est attaquée et
boris qui a immédiatement recycler son
cavalier à 5 et qui n'était plus utile
donc sur la case bessette donc boris qui
va probablement au maître ce cavalier
sur d8 voilà donc et il pourra peut-être
après essayer d'ouvrir la colonne à part
à 6 libéré un petit peu son jeu de
pièces mais là arnaud donc il ya une
ouverture tout à fait correct mais il
faut se méfier des contres chance noir
donc aller le roi les noirs qui tôt ou
tard pourront se montrer menaçant les
lois mais laboris développe ses pièces
il il attaque le pion des cinq par fou
17 donc les blondes
toujours défendre ce plan b 5
malheureusement sur cavalière 4g 5
pourrait être possible donc la dame va
peut-être devoir cavaliers f4 donc
arnaud attends attends est-ce que j'ai
cinq est possible peut-être pas tout de
suite en tout cas ça ça viendra tôt ou
tard donc tour c'est 8 h 4 pour éviter
éventuellement toutes ces possibilités
de contres je fous h6 la position qui
est encore assez équilibré un oui mais
on a le sentiment que les blancs ont un
avantage d'espacé qu'ils ont quand même
plus de possibilités à cause de la
faiblesse du pion en c7 et pourquoi pas
avec la possibilité de jouer à un moment
un coup comme h un coup de préparer
cette poussée pour essayer de d'attaqué
à l'endroit quand on n'aura pas réglé le
problème du roi g1 pourquoi pas l'amener
en manger deux fois trois rangées de
tours à chiens pour essayer d'attaquer
sur ce côté de l'échiquier y mais il
faut quand même faire remarquer que le
fou j'ai deux n'est pas très bien placé
et que le pion des cinq est tristement
emprise donc à arnaud a compris ça et
ils décident de troquer ce pion des 5
contre le pion à 7 donc mais boris ne
veut pas donner le pion à sète il veut
piquer le pion dessins que c'est tout
donc voilà donc le temps donc les noirs
en trois minutes 06 les blancs en trois
minutes 10 les joueurs jouent très très
vite donc et le pion des cinq fours et
faim pour défendre le clan des sacs fous
ces quatre défend le pion des cinq dames
17 donc la dame à trois tours à huit
pour défendre le pion à 7
oui comme j'ai dit la position est très
très solide les noirs sont très solides
du nul leur suffit donc dame c8 four b3
d'amd 8
boris attend il attend et là arnaud va
essayer d'attaquer le pion c7 peut-être
en essayant de tripler ses pièces à 4 à
très bonne idée oui boris qui va qui
verrouille la position si les blancs
prennent en a cinq la tour pour
reprendre 1,5 et éventuellement
éventuellement venir en a cinq dons que
arnaud ne veux pas ça maintenant il va
essayer de tripler sur le pont on sait
mais ce n'est pas facile la position est
très très verrouillé c'est très très dur
pour les blancs de prendre l'avantagé
dans cette position le temps on va
également être un facteur très important
dans cette fin de partie donc le cavaly
qui a reçu des songes et 4 donc pour
l'instant boris favori mais arnaud
trouve du contre je pars h
il sait qu'il faut qu'ils ouvrent la
position il le fait immédiatement
entourage un cavalier
donc le pion h qui va probablement
prendre en g6 oui c'est fait donc
maintenant et arnaud qui va peut-être
essayer de doubler sur la colonne âge
pour retrouver du contre jeu ailleurs
donc ils commencent par tour h4 donc
hélas boris qui prend le pion en d5
concarneau a décidé de sacrifier ce pion
mais la position est extrêmement ouverte
boris qu'il veut échanger les dames
parce qu'il a un pion de plus c'est
qu'il est et qu'il est mieux tout
simplement donc que va faire arnaud dans
cette position arnaud donc décide de
refuser donc en par des 5 et d'ouvrir
les cases de d'ouvrir d'obtenir un
maximum de contre jeu donc il est à
sacrifier deux pions mais après dame
prendre des 5
il va peut-être essayer de jouer dame b2
est fou des cats par exemple pour
hausser de d'affaiblir ou dams et 3 pour
prendre le contrôle de la grande
diagonale à 1 h 8 et l'a donc dam des
trois on entre dans une finale bourhis a
rendu le pion il est boris et mieux donc
tout va se jouer autant donc dans cette
position donc il faut quand même se
méfier de donc du fou de cases noires
qui pourraient peut-être être sacrifié
sur un des deux pions donc on cloue ça
c'est bien la tour se recycler les plus
utiles sur la première rangée le royans
es7 et la tour qui vient en donc dans
cette position je ne suis pas très bien
les coups ça va très très vite donc le
cavaliere f6 les blancs attendre essaye
de progresser il le roi va essayer de
rentrer sur des 5 c 6 pour
éventuellement piqué le pion ses sets le
qualifié sur la jungle au roi pour s
donc rien n'est si clair donc arnaud qui
joue très très bien c'est fin de partie
et laboris qui décident de réagir un
petit peu en mettant son cavalier à eux
quatre donc voilà donc une position très
très tendu donc des joueurs en pleine
concentration il reste une minute 13 à
arnaud hauchard et 2 minutes 15 à boris
qui a beaucoup d'avancé autant qu'il ya
beaucoup d' avance au temps et là dans
cette position arnaud qui transpose en
finale donc en finale deux tours le pion
c'est en c5 et passez donc arnaud ne
pourra pas échanger facilement les
pièces il faut qu'ils se méfient du
penser mais il active ces pièces tout
toujours donc une finale probablement
encore égal mais où tout est possible
vraiment une fin de partie incroyable
donc dans cette position arnaud qui
attend et laboris qui propose un échange
de tour ah oui c'est très désagréable
puisque après temps 17 tours 7
les blancs ont
non plus n'ont plus d'autre possibilité
que de répéter la position
donc à moins à moins qu'ils échangent
les tours mais non ce n'est pas possible
boris de ce doit se contenter de la nul
donc à la arnaud décident d'échanger
mais malheureusement cette position est
sans espoir puisque il n'est pas
possible d'avoir un pur passer à l'est
le roi et que les noirs ont un pion pas
ces allèles dame ce qui est suffisant
pour aller à dame
donc voilà boris qui replace qui
recentralise sont rois petit à petit et
qui dans sa prison gagne oui bravo
qualification donc de boris spassky qui
n'a pas perdu cette position contre
arnaud hauchard qui a fait le maximum
vraiment un match superbe
jean luc maurice parce qu'ils jouent
alors je suis content je suis qui
commencera qu'à 17h30
donc ils sont partis incroyable et très
bonne forme et peut-être est-ce que si
vous m'entendez ensemble se nourrissent
de match 3-0 reese qui reste très calme
après la fin de son match arnaud dette
et commentaires mais j'ai peut-être
loupé ma chanson la partie d'avant
peut-être si je les partage je sais pas
en fait 6 il faut mieux prendre les
noirs ou les blancs contre borisov vous
allez peut-être mais pour les noirs ça
serait un choix à faire la prochaine
fois alors peut-être peut-être de même
pour la petite finale alors dans
l'urgence j'ai dû décider voilà donc on
va faire une petite pause maintenant
donc maintenant vous avez une collation
qui vous attend au dessus au salon rené
coty donc
je vous invite à y aller 20 minutes de
pause à peu près avant de voir le second
match de la journée entre jouer lautier
et safety of